hey leute fast gedacht und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen sehr spontan
video von alex ihrem youtube analyse
experten abonniert mich viel spaß was
gedacht ich hoffe euch geht's gut
heute ist feiertag in ganz deutschland
und ich hab mir gedacht er heute machst
du eigentlich mal gar nichts außer ein
bisschen eine präsentation vorbereiten
für meine uni und das war's eigentlich
als ich wollte heute eigentlich gar kein
video machen ich war jetzt die letzten
zwei stunden allerdings mal wieder
intensiv auf youtube unterwegs haben mir
so anguckt was abgeht und ich habe bis
jetzt von den beiden videos die die
bilder hochgeladen hat noch gar keines
gesehen also das eine ist schon moment
das ist schon vier tage alt kam vor vier
tagen online normalerweise kriege ich
immer relativ schnell von irgend etwas
mit wenn irgendwas jetzt geheilt wird
sage ich mal aber davon habe ich
wirklich gar nichts mitbekommen weder
von promiflash noch von wieder von
promiflash noch von es gibt es noch
statik oder so und noch irgendwas
verlieren aber ich weiß es gerade nicht
ja keine ahnung war mir komplett neu so
und ich habe mir dann eben dieses video
angeguckt und zwar ist da so eine
ja so ein pfeil als titel beschreibung
den einige als spermien gedeutet haben
ich habe mir eben kommentare
durchgelesen schafft mir oh man ja auf
jeden fall werden wir eben das video
vorgeschlagen was sie heute hochgeladen
hat ich habe mich dann aber zuerst mal
dieses video angeschaut was zum tablett
her eigentlich gleich aussah und auch
von der länge des videos kann man rechts
in der ecke sehen ich habe es also als
story gedeutet und ist ja auch so als
wenn wir uns dieses videos nochmals
zusammen anschauen den kommentaren
stellt ganz oft dass leute irgendwie
diese zwölfter entdeckt haben und das
wohl für schwanger steht oder so was
immer wir schon kurz weiter da ich kaum
noch irgendwo was ich glaube aber nicht
ob es eben einmal durch geguckt ja das
video besteht aus diesem unter 12 und
dann stehen wir solche kommentare
darunter wie auf dem video sind neun
streifen ist das zufall man ist ja
meistens auch neun monate lang schwanger
und die 12 bedeutete dann ihre zwölften
schwangerschaftswoche
hoffentlich kommt heute die auflösung
wir auch auf die auflösung wartet like
ja wo man wie ich mache mir sorgen ich
stelle mir vor es wäre so cool wenn du
meine mama was haye und daran kann man
schon erkennen gut ich habe natürlich
auch nicht sehr sehr junge zielgruppe
detail aber es haben sich wirklich
anscheinend sehr sehr viele leute sorgen
gemacht und in den kommentaren und einen
sämtlichen anderen videos die ich mir
jetzt und zu dem thema angeschaut habt
wieder spekuliert dass sie schwanger ist
und jetzt irgendwie übermorgen dann
sagte sie schwanger ist ein steht leute
soll ich eigentlich aufgefallen dass
promiflash noch kein video drüber
gemacht hat oder habe ich etwas verpasst
wäre das geht mir genauso ich habe es
auch nicht mitbekommen so also das ist
dieses video 2,2 millionen klicks schon
nach vier tagen für sein kurzes video
ist natürlich echt stark aber sogar ich
schaue mir an sollen jetzt gehen wir
kurz mal auf den channel wo habe ich gar
nicht abonniert aber schnell nachholen
ich muss natürlich auch noch kurz sagen
ich habe absolut nichts gegen baby nur
ja er werde gleich mehr dazu erfahren
was ich jetzt zu dem ganzen sein würde
so wir schauen uns dieses video jedoch
durch einen punkt punkt punkt bei
gemacht
das video wird ebenfalls 15 sekunden das
muss ich mir sofort war in meinem
kalender hier eintragen damit ich das
auch auf keinen fall verpassen
milito www video geil gut das haben wir
natürlich uns schon mal notiert und sehr
viele haben sich wohl gedacht heute
kommt dann die aufwertung zum thema baby
wird sagen jetzt ich bin schwanger
ganz toll juli alles freut sich auch
sehr samstag zwölfter fünfter 2018 hat
bitte noch etwas geduld wir brauchen
noch etwas zeit ihr werdet es verstehen
es geht uns gut keine sorge ich habe ein
beweisfoto von bibi dass sie schwanger
ist wer es sehen will soll abonnieren
und mir einen kommentar schreiben
das machen wir natürlich erst mal weil
das interessiert mich auch brennend und
wenn ich jetzt hier den sportlern spaß
als wenn ich dich abonniert habe ich
eben auch schon raus bekommen
ich denke jetzt auch wahrscheinlich
denken jetzt viele von euch was laberst
du die ganze zeit eigentlich gerade das
weiß ich doch auch denkt schon babys
beauty palace aber ich glaube es geht um
irgendeinen foto warte mal genau es geht
einfach um dieses foto weil sie da wohl
etwas dicker aussieht was ich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann ich
dieses fotos auch keine ahnung gerade
mal zehn tage alt und hier sieht sie
absolut normal aus als wenn sie jetzt in
fünf tagen deutlich dicker geworden ist
oder so also wäre es bei uns jetzt
abonniert hat da kann ich auch nur mit
dem kopf schütteln
und jetzt habe ich schon ganz viel
blöden müller erzählt und wir das sei
immer noch mal angeguckt und jetzt lässt
sich eigentlich nur an den gesunden
menschenverstand appellieren erstmal
muss man sagen baby hat wirklich eine
menge junger zuschauer natürlich noch
viel mehr als ich das habe und daran so
ein video rauszuhauen wo ganz viele
kleine kinder kommentieren und wie was
ist los mit dir geht's dir gut wirst du
noch mit julian zusammen ist irgendwas
man sich sorgen machen
jetzt schauen wir die eine sache was ich
euch jetzt aber zu 100 prozent sagen
kann
erstens weil ich selber youtuber bin und
zweitens weil
also wenn das video von ihr was in zwei
tagen dann rauskommt nicht meiner
theorie entspricht dann fresse ich einen
besen leute ohne spaß
wortwörtlich sogar ich fresse ich einen
besen also gut man kann wesentlich
komplett essen aber ein stück vom wesen
es stellen und zwar geht es ganz einfach
um ein neues produkt das sie am samstag
um 12 uhr euch präsentieren wir ob das
jetzt be lu ist ob das irgendwas anderes
ist keine ahnung das kann ich auch nicht
sagen stellt euch doch mal vor wie blöd
das wäre man macht eiskalt über die
schwangerschaft zwei promo videos dass
eine vor vier tagen das andere heute und
dann kommt am samstag die auflösung
leute ja ich bin schwanger
was denkt sich denn dann das kind dabei
wenn der oder die das irgendwann mal
scheiße meine geburt waren reine
produktion
na ja meine mama ist halt auch babys
beauty pearls was will man da erwarten
natürlich kann es vielleicht sein dass
wir wie von vornherein gedacht hat wenn
das vielleicht so gedeutet wird als wäre
ich schwanger erzählt das natürlich noch
viel größere aufmerksamkeit aber da gehe
ich erstmal nicht von außen also das
glaube ich wirklich nicht nur trotzdem
muss man hier mal wieder den hut ziehen
vor unserem marketing genie babys beauty
palace das ist ja wirklich gut also wenn
es jetzt wirklich irgend einen total
ausgefallenes neues cooles produktes
würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht anders
machen ja aber sie ist zu 100 prozent
garantieren nicht schwanger und das
wollte ich einfach mal kurz mit diesem
video sagt und falls es doch der fall
sein sollte
ich habe es euch ja gesagt haben 30
probiere ich machen gewesen
ich noch kurz ergänzen wollte hier in
der beschreibung von dem neuen video
seht ihr ab bitte noch etwas geduld wir
brauchen noch etwas zeit dieses wir
brauchen noch etwas zeit verstärkt ja
gerade diesen gedanken ich bin schwanger
also könnte ich also meine theorie
dahinter wäre einfach
sie hat jetzt gemerkt dass das erste
video dazu bewegt hat das sehr sehr
viele gedacht haben ich fürchte sie
schwanger und durch diese video
beschreibung wie das ganze natürlich
noch mal verstärkt das heißt dass da
noch mehr aufsehen
und wir brauchen noch etwas zeit hat ja
an sich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun
dass ein produkt bald neue rauskommt
aber ich bin natürlich immer noch der
meinung dass das absolut nichts mit
einer schwangerschaft zu tun hat sondern
mit einem produkt das wir kommen soll
macht es nicht ja das war ein sehr
kurzes video und das war es dann auch
schon wir sehen uns glaube ich samstag
wieder rein